who killed nail nastrad this is one of
the toughest mysteries to crack in all
of hunter hunter because it has all the
makings of an agatha christie novel we
have a victim we also have a number of
culprits who have motivation and
opportunity to kill them and of course
one big twist that brings us to a very
unexpected conclusion but why would
anyone target this innocent looking girl
emphasis on innocent looking because
appearances are very deceptive but neon
nastrad was the daughter of mafia boss
zlatnistrad a family that rose to power
exceptionally quickly due to neon's nen
ability named lovely ghost writer and
this is one of the more absurd nun
abilities in the series and i know i
know i say that a lot in these videos
but that's more so because i don't tend
to talk about the more mundane ones like
revels or a blast which allows him to
move his wheelchair like really fast
truly powersome but lovely ghostwriter
is essentially an end beast which now
can summon after fulfilling a couple of
basic requirements and the beast will
then control neon to write a delightful
poem in four or five quatrains that
predicts the target's future for the
next four weeks or so now because it's a
poem it does require interpretation and
the language can be easily
misinterpreted because a lot of the time
it is deliberately vague however if one
is a particularly astutely brained
individual then this information can be
used as sort of a cheat code for life
and that is exactly how lightnesstrod
came into prominence he used his
daughter's precognition to take all of
the right steps and eventually he
started selling access to this power for
extortionately high prices and lovely
ghostwriter is a perfect business
because it naturally generates repeat
customers due to the fact that it can
only predict about a month into the
future but with great power comes well a
great amount of people who simply don't
like you or want to take advantage of
said power or just want to take that
power for themselves this is exactly
what happened in the case of one crolo
lucifer after discovering neon's ability
krollo successfully stole it using his
own skill hunter hatsu meanwhile
karopika set his sights on the nastrad
family because naon wanted to collect
the scarlet eyes of his clan and so he
ended up sneakifying his way in as
bodyguard and then we have lovable
murder clown hisoka who experienced
lovely ghost rider first hand during
york new city which if not for a texture
surprise would have caused him
immeasurable problems and then let's not
forget all of the old money mafia
families who are less than pleased with
the rise of the nostrada
version organization so what we end up
with here is a very basic recipe for
deep fried chaos and by the time we
reach the succession war it is revealed
to us that crollow no longer has access
to the lovely ghost writer ability
meaning that nao nastrad is dead and not
only that but she was killed by one of
the people i've already mentioned that's
right it's a very classic mansion
mystery here because the murderer is
still within the property so who killed
nail nastrad well i'll tell you but
first something else this video is
sponsored by ebony the king's return a
free to play strategy mmo game thing
which allows you to experience various
puzzle levels in order to expand your
empire and become king of all over the
seven kingdom places and you can choose
from seven different civilizations to
customize your game's architectural
style architectural is a surprisingly
hard word for me to say today your
game's architectural style the game
features over 1 000 puzzle levels
designed to challenge your mind brain
with critical thinking across an
incredibly diverse range of puzzle-based
scenarios which i like because it has
been scientifically proven that people
who do puzzles are morally superior to
those who don't so don't be the don't
even also allows you to join mighty
alliances with friends or even make new
friends featuring real-time
communication via voice and text kind of
like how i'm talking to you right now
you can download ebony using the link in
the description and it's recommended to
get it via the amazon app store so go do
that thing but for now it's back to you
me so who killed nail nastrad well let's
begin with suspect number one karapika a
man capable of endless complex thought
with a very simple motivation being
revenge neon was obsessive about
collecting the kurta rise which drove
karapika into a deep state of depression
especially considering that it was
ultimately his job to acquire them for
her so the idea here is that krapika
eventually snapped and took revenge on
one of the many body part collectors
that had inspired the phantom troop to
commit their genocide to begin with
because when it comes to any product
including disembodied eyeballs supply
only exists due to demand the troop
would not have harvested the eyes if
people like neon did not exist her
desires are the root of krapika's
suffering furthermore krapika went on to
become the big boss of the nastrad
family with no word of what happened to
either light or neon i mean there is
word of neon she's dead that's why we're
here but we don't know how and this
means that the two of them have
seemingly rather conveniently
disappeared leaving karapika to inherit
the organization so there's another
potential motive there to grab power
however karapika is not the killer and
we know this because after murder
fighting overkin karapika has been very
honest about his exploits through an
inner monologue and although he has
quote threatened coaxed paid off and
committed other various unsavory acts to
recover the scarlet eyes he has yet to
kill again very importantly here krapika
may be exonerated of the deed itself but
he's in way too deep here he's still
involved and we will find out exactly
how shortly before that we need to
examine suspect number the second which
is hisoka and in my opinion he is the
obvious answer i don't call him a murder
clown for non-murderous reasons hisoka
is one of if not the most trigger-happy
character in all of the hunter hunter
however in this case hisoka's motive
goes a lot deeper than simple psychosis
hisoka has experienced the power of
lovely ghostwriter first hand although
more importantly he experienced the
power in crollow's hand
it should be noted that lovely
ghostwriter cannot be used to predict
its user's future however if kroller
were constantly churning out fortunes
like cookies for the rest of the phantom
troupe then they would be able to spend
an entire lifetime dodging hisoka's
advances and by advances i mean
bloodthirsty drive to kill murder each
and every one of them there is a slight
conflict here in that generally hisoka
prefers his opponents to be as powerful
as possible because it makes his clown
peen that much harder but even clown
peen has a limit and when hisoka gets
serious he figures out his opponent's
ability counters it and then kills them
and hisoka right now is very serious
about killing the entire phantom troop
so i think it makes a whole ton of sense
for him to go after nail nostrad in
order to eliminate one of crowler's most
powerful hatsu assets and i think this
is especially true of post heaven's
arena hisoka after he was revived from
death hisoka was done playing with his
food it is time to trump and now nastrad
being alive is a big problem for him
it's also quite in keeping with hisoka's
current order of operations by which i
mean dispatching both charnock and
cortopia as they also possessed very
useful abilities which crollo borrowed
in order to defeat hisoka thinking about
it it must be pretty terrifying to be
crowler right now to just sit there with
with your fun book thing and watch your
abilities disappear one by one it's
terrifying there's even a world where
hisoka is second hand responsible due to
hiring illimi or another zoldic to
murder neon whilst hisoka was off
chasing krollo for a year hisoka just
has everything going for him everything
going for him in terms of being a child
murderer that is he has the motive he
had the opportunity and he has the
resources to pull off whenever he so
chooses and after he pulls off he can
then kill neon so hisoka is certainly
still a very suspicious suspect his
motives are logical and his opportunity
plentiful a very likely suspect indeed
but perhaps too likely so let's switch
this up and look at a bit of a startling
candidate suspect number three light
nostrad now this may sound a bit
ridiculous because light ah he was such
an adoring father ready and willing to
fulfill all of the daughter whims and
also being very overly concerned for her
safety which is nice and all but light
he wasn't exactly the man he betrayed
himself to be in public light was a
businessman first and foremost he
started the nostrad family as a street
gang with a handful of members and then
began using his daughter's powers as his
organization's primary source of revenue
also consider this light's ultimate and
short-lived ambition in hunter hunter is
to quote rule the world which is quite
ambitious but light was never concerned
for neon he was concerned for his
business and his future as the god king
of hunter hunter and after it's revealed
that neon lost her ability light has a
complete mental breakdown he is very
fearful on the brink and a man in a
state where he is capable of doing
anything the motive here is that he
kills neon in an act of vengeance for
losing his only revenue stream which no
doesn't make logical sense like hisoka's
candidacy but it's a crime of passion
and those rarely make logical sense i do
have a bit of a hard time believing this
personally because naon being alive is
still an indispensable asset as her
ability could be returned at any time
following certain circumstances like say
if crowler was killed for example but
again crimes of passion rarely makes
sense and in light's state of mental
breakdown it very well could have
happened but it's also important to look
at the reason why light was pushed to
this state which is suspect number four
a rival mafia family as previously
mentioned the nastrad family was a force
of disruption in the underworld rising
stars who went from nothing to all of
the things with the stroke of a pen
there are a lot of underworld powers who
hold quite a bit of resentment for
encroaching on the territory or those
who wish to abduct neon and use her
power for themselves which would have
been very easy because light can no
longer see into the future to prevent it
but after discovering that she is
powerless then neon just becomes another
sack of meat on the supermarket shelf of
life and is thus very easily disposable
but shockingly enough there is an even
darker possibility as suspect number
five is nail nostrad herself suicide
essentially the motive being that after
losing her power neon fell into a deep
dark depression potentially due to
disappointing her father and him not
indulging her whims anymore and so she
took her own life it seems unlikely
because the last we actually saw of neon
certainly didn't paint her in this kind
of mental pit and she was more curious
you know wondering why she couldn't use
the abilities anymore what's wrong ghost
writer son can come out but this also
happens to be the very last time we saw
neo nastrada live which was during greed
island that was before neon knew how mad
the situation had driven her father and
the possibilities for future despair are
very unfortunately deep now at this
point just in case there's some
confusion this channel is not some kind
of dodgy massage parlor and as such we
don't usually provide happy endings but
i will indulge you on this one occasion
because suspect number six is that there
is no suspect and nail nastrad is still
alive one possibility being that skill
hunter is considered to be an end curse
and is thus able to be dispelled by a
competent and exorcist that is
information karapika would certainly
know as he is a nen curse user himself
but there is also another option during
the succession war croppika revealed a
new ability called steel chain this
allows him to inject a target force them
into a state of zetsu and steal one of
their nen abilities which naturally
brings up the question of what would
happen if the same nen user were
targeted by two different nen theft
abilities crollo initially took lovely
ghostwriter through skill hunter however
that heart 2 does not recognize crolo as
the ability user as it is still tied to
the life of its original owner so if
krapika would then target naon again
stealing her ability does that mean that
he would take lovely ghost writer and
result in the power vanishing from skill
hunter it's a very tricky mechanical
nanny question but it also gets more
complicated one in that karapika needs a
completely separate nen dolphin to use
his stolen powers but also after that
use the power is returned to its user so
i guess the logic here is that krapika
injects neon he takes lovely ghost
writer uses it on someone you know makes
a lovely little prediction and then the
ability is returned to neon as per the
conditions of steel chain because naon
is lovely ghost writer's recognized user
meanwhile crowler checks his book sees
that the power has vanished and assumes
that that can only mean that neon is
dead and as perfect as an ending as this
would be i just i don't think that's how
things played out crollo after noticing
the ability was gone wouldn't have just
shrugged and said oh well lol because
lovely ghostwriter was just too powerful
to abandon like that with his resources
and intelligence network crollo could
have found out whether or not neon was
still alive and if she was and it might
have been a real good idea to go and
find out exactly what happened to say
the least crawler really isn't the kind
of guy to just accept vague and easy
answers and from his conversation with
shizuku he clearly believes that naon is
dead so in my opinion i think that
hisoka is the most likely suspect
followed by light and then followed by
naon herself i highly doubt it was a
rival family because in cropica's care
nobody nobody is getting that girl i
mean not unless there's some kind of
phenomenal net user which leaves me with
hisoka because he is one such an end
user with the perfect motive the perfect
resources and the perfect opportunity he
is the easy occam's razor but i'm afraid
that until we have firm evidence one way
or the other the murder of dale nastrad
will remain unsolved